hey there i'm philip molina and on this
channel we analyze and dissect and have
a lot of fun sharing as many little
miserable moments as we can in our
favorite nerd properties like get ready
because just like the trailer before it
star wars the force awakens the movie is
insanely packed with references and
easter eggs and cameos and interesting
imagery all sorts of trivia and i'm just
preparing you because this is gonna be a
huge video but totally worth it because
there's so much cool stuff and i
definitely think we actually spotted a
few things that i haven't seen anywhere
else
oh and obviously with the movie being so
jam-packed they had to cut a thing or
two but lucky for you I've got a good
idea on what those deleted scenes were
and I'll go over those too now if you
think I miss anything feel free to let
me know in the comments but there's a
good chance we already covered it in one
of our other Star Wars references and
easter eggs videos for the trailer
breakdowns so check those out after this
if you want to see even more alright
going in order as it played out in the
movie let's get to it
spoilers galore starting at the
beginning the opening shot of the film
which is up there as maybe one of the
coolest looking ones they've ever done
shows us a new level of Star Destroyer
eclipsing a planet the Star Destroyers
called the finalizar and this epic ship
is twice as big as the old-school Star
Destroyers and it actually had to be
built in secret because it really
blatantly violates the treaty between
the first order and the New Republic but
since this epic shot is also the first
thing we see you might not be surprised
that there's some interesting imagery
choices going on here to the tip of the
finalizer very much resembles the cross
guard of kylo Ren's lightsaber and this
ship with that cross guard style mass
begins to block out all of the light in
the shot almost completely bringing
darkness to the planet below but when
there's just the tiniest sliver of light
left a few ships shoot out of its side
escaping through the light specifically
including the ship that Finn is on cool
right JJ did a lot of this kind of stuff
in this movie moving on in Star Wars the
language we hear our main characters
speak sounds a lot like English but they
call it basic however the first non
basic words of the movie are some
concerned beeps from bb-8 when he sees
the first order approaching to Koo but
first English or basic words that are
spoken are by Max von Sydow as lor San
Tekka and his line is this should begin
to make
things right that's the first line of
the first Star Wars movies since the not
love prequels so another translation
that might be like damn shots fired
lor San Tekka and JJ v an unofficial
translation that movie not company when
the troop transporters carrying finn
land on the sands of jakku their design
and the choreography in the
cinematography they're all nods to the
landing crafts touching down on the
sands of Omaha Beach specifically the
way it was depicted in one of JJ's
mentors movies Saving Private Ryan
directed by Steven Spielberg in both
movies we get shots of the concerned
soldiers packed into the vessels and
they can't see where they're about to
land but the moment the vessel doors
lowered the soldiers up front are
immediately killed chaos then ensues and
when Finn spaces out due to all the
violence it's almost identical to the
way Tom Hanks paces out also not being
able to comprehend it all JJ's borrowing
that movie's realistic depiction of
invasion and the surrounding tragedy to
make us right out of the gate realize
these stormtroopers are actual people
who are actually dying and that's all
before we've even seen one of them take
their helmets off also this isn't the
only World War 2 reference in the movie
but that's later let's keep going the
x-wing that Poe jumps into but is
quickly disabled is actually not fancy
new technology it's more of a modified
version of what the rebels already had
back in the original trilogy and the
point of this reference is to show us
that the resistance is not well-funded
they are working off what is now very
old technology meanwhile the first-order
moments later shows off their fancy
brand-new ships when kylo Ren arrives
and his personal exelon class shuttle
it's twice as big and way newer than
Vader's old lambda Class shuttle and
it's obviously like nine Greek letters
better a few months later we see one of
the most memorable amazing moments in
the movie when kylo Ren uses his force
abilities to freeze a freaking blaster
bolt midair considering blaster bolts
are kind of like shooting Blazers that's
something we've never seen the force do
manipulate light energy the way that
beam freezes in the way it looks I mean
it's weird to say this but it's actually
scientifically accurate and that's
because I'm pretty sure that filmmakers
studied this actual experiment in real
life where Star Wars obsessed scientists
wanted to see what it would look like to
freeze up
blaster-bolt midair also this new
manipulating of light that the force can
do it's not our only new force ability
but let's keep going now it's well known
that the legendary John Williams came
back to compose the music for the force
awakens but that means that JJ wasn't
able to go to his go-to composer for
everything from Ilyas to Star Trek
Michael chiquinho that guy is totally
great too he won the Oscar for score for
up I can still hum like every score from
wasbut chiquinho actually considers John
Williams to be his hero he even said
he'd rather hear new Star Wars music
from John Williams than from himself he
got rewarded because he's the
stormtrooper that pushes Poe Dameron
down in front of kylo Ren so it's a
pretty good trade a few moments later
when bb-8 sees the explosion and he
thinks poe might be dead his sounds are
incredibly emotional and sad and that
makes sense considering actual humans
performed bb-8 voice you might already
know that it was actually Bill Hader and
John Ralphy himself Ben Schwartz and it
really is their performance because what
they did is they spoke words and made
sounds into an iPad app that digitized
their voices into robotic sound fun Bill
Hader fact he's actually a huge Star
Wars nerd and like ten years ago he was
begging to be a lowly production
assistant on this Star Wars documentary
just because he loved it so much and I'm
also not surprised that he got the job
as bb-8 voice because a lot of people
don't remember years ago he used to go
around doing these amazing impressions
of non-human Star Wars characters
they're just so good watch how good your
Jabba the Hutt dying
[Laughter]
[Applause]
amazing and for Ben Schwartz here's a
video of another time that he added his
voice to a part of Star Wars that
doesn't really use words okay then we
meet Captain phasma who's our first game
of Thrones cameo Gwendoline Christie and
while you probably didn't know that a
lot of people don't know that her shiny
armor it's purposely made to stand out
within the Star Wars universe because
she wants it to be a symbol in Star Wars
history it turns out it's actually
melted down from one of those chromium
ships that they use on the Emperor and
Padma's homeworld Naboo and her armor
specifically came from one of the
Emperor ships so phasma uses it as a
symbol of his power then rey scavenges
and there's a specific moment where she
pulls out a salvaged old Star Destroyer
part it's a capacitor bearing but the
framing of this shot is very purposely
mirrored almost exactly in a much more
climactic moment later in the movie when
rey is pulling out parts of the fancy
new star killer base and the way she
repels around these old destroyer walls
it's also mimicked in her escape from
the new vessels interrogation area so
it's just a bunch of setups and payoffs
Rey then takes her findings back on her
speeder and sure it has some
similarities to luke speeder but it's
actually hard place what kind of speeder
it is and that's because as it turns out
rey built it herself from other parts
she scavenged in fact you might not have
noticed there's no seat she's sitting on
the engine and the engine is a recycled
podracer engines there's also other
podracer parts floating around on jakku
and the tattered podracer flags at maz
kanata's castle they all give us a
detail that's pretty easy to miss in
this time of the Star Wars universe no
hun podraces anymore I usually get that
because a silly spectator sport doesn't
make as much sense once the Emperor
takes over and everything's terrible
can't say I miss it either though whoa
and the movie doesn't have a ton of nods
to the prequels but there are some then
we get another epically beautiful shot
where ray cruises past the outside of
the Down Star Destroyer and it's
actually known to be the inflictor it
was a story that went down back in the
battle of jakku and has a whole story
about why it's crashed into that very
spot in the sand if you want to know
that story it's in the new Star Wars
book lost stars I'll put a link to the
description to it but what I think is
cool is about this shot and a shot we
get a little later where she's standing
behind a Super Star Destroyer is it's
the first time we've actually been able
to grasp the scale of these huge ships
next to a human being it finally gives
us a relative size for all those shots
that are in space and holy crap that
means all those battles are so massive
Raven dragsters Cavan jeans - unkar
plutt who seems to run things here on
email post and the actor underneath that
blob eNOS happens to be Simon Pegg his
voice was heavily altered but he's
actually really in there wearing all
that stuff
Star Wars I'd burn this hour only his
facial expressions were enhanced with
CGI it's also fun a note that simon
Pegg's one of the stars of the new Star
Trek movies and he's writing the new one
so I guess he can join Finn in the list
of really likeable traitors when Rey
goes home he'd get a really good look at
her belongings including this little
rebel pilot doll that she clearly made
herself and would probably do really
well if she sold it on Etsy but she
clearly has a thing about rebel pilots
later she's outside of her home which is
a down to 8080 or at if you say it that
way I'll let you guys debate that in the
comments but anyway when she goes out
there she puts on an old rebel flight
helmet and as she imagines what it would
be like to be a rebel pilot you can see
on this side the Star Wars are best
letters flesh and an her which in
English spell are AE H as in rey and
that's not just some cute production
designer joke though the helmets
markings actually mean it belongs to the
tear fin yellow a specifically captained
Osment rey a female x-wing pilot so
here's my theory considering how
obsessed rey is with this pilot and her
adventures and how little she seems to
know about her own path couldn't it be
the case that rey actually named herself
after captain ray like having forgotten
her own original name it wouldn't mirror
how kylo ren chose to go by a new name
when he changes identities isla Ren is
actually been
ray could be BAE BAE Skywalker for bacon
Obi that's terrible note forget the bay
part the theory kind of holds up no BAE
moving on cry rescues bb-8 from Tito's
net and I'm pretty sure that's the
moment where a Star Wars character says
Jubjub I think Tito mutters it right
there if you don't know by the way
Jubjub is this trademark phrase of conan
o'brien's it means nothing he just loves
it he put it in the Simpsons it was the
Iguana Jeb JEB is fantastic back JJ to
put it in Star Wars and you got choked
up in I did this is fantastic
pretty sure that's where it is and
speaking of trademark phrases when ray
tells bb-8 to stay off Kelvin Ridge it's
a reference to JJ Abrams as grandfather
Henry Kelvin he actually puts that in
all of his projects it was big and lost
it's a major ship in Star Trek so now
you can add Kelvin Ridge to that list
that's on the finalizar Poe played by
Oscar Isaac being forced tortured and
interrogated by kylo Ren and just
outside the room is general Hawkes
played by Donald Gleeson now a lot of
people like to point out that Isaacs and
Gleeson were in a movie together about a
very advanced droid called ex machina
and that movie's great actually I don't
think it's nearly as fun as reminding
people that kylo and Poe word a movie
together too
that scene is equally intense back on
jakku the only quick thing worth
pointing out is that hunker plug refers
to BBA as a him and then throughout the
entire rest of the movie people call
bb-8 him and then why not seem unusual
except almost all the way up until the
film's release
bb-8 was confirmed to be a girl that's
because Lucas films president Kathleen
Kennedy referred to her as a girl and so
did the designers of BBA so why do
people keep calling it a him they don't
give us much of an answer actually they
just say that somewhere in the design
changes they change something about bb-8
that made him definitively a boy and
like the only thing I can think is that
somewhere along the line they added a
wiener like I don't know how they would
be able to just suddenly shift genders
thinking about it I guess they wouldn't
really want to have to explain why two
dudes were hired to do the voice of a
female that sounds way more plausible
actually than then adding a wiener it
just it just wouldn't be practical
you can't you wouldn't be able to roll
with it that's more on the finalizar we
see Finn take off his stormtrooper
helmet and reveal to Poe that he's
rescuing him and it's a direct reference
to Luke's revealing to Leia in a new
hope I'm Luke Skywalker I'm here to
rescue you then as Finn and Poe try and
make their escape we get our best look
at petty officers Anacin he's actually
Game of Thrones cameo number two Thomas
brodie-sangster you might better
remember him as the adorably horny
little kid from Love Actually
unfortunately if you're a big fan of his
that's all you get cuz he dies like 10
seconds later in that same escape scene
you actually also hear the infamous
Wilhelm scream that's in every Star Wars
movie oh and Finn scape on the TIE
fighters and the finalizer fires the
ventral cannons we see some really
unusual blasts rather than the lasers
were used to I mean one of those things
takes out the whole side of the TIE
fighter and the thing is this could be
part of this huge reveal in the way the
first order works now apparently the new
Star Destroyer or the finalizar it has a
brand new weapon that is very expensive
and very special because it's powered by
Kyber crystals and why is that matter
Kyber crystals are what Jedi's used to
make lightsabers the bad guys sit sabers
are usually made using these knockoff
synthetic crystals but not the Jedi's
and actually
I'll run Sabre either but the fact that
the first order is now using weapons
powered by Kyber crystals tells us that
the first order is actually using
technology powered by the force so that
means Snoke is intermingling the first
order and the darkside way more than the
original Empire ever did which is gonna
make a huge difference when the first
order is trying to take on Jedi's
also while Finn and power escaping we
get the reveal that finn doesn't
actually have a name but rather he's
referred to by his number fn-2187
now there's one kind of obvious
reference there because cell to one
eight seven is where they found Princess
Leia way back on the Death Star
here it is but the number 207 is itself
a bigger reference to the 1963 short
film 2187 directed by arthur Lipsett
it's one of those super artsy short
films it's like all in black and white
but it completely inspired George Lucas
and is making of Star Wars like I'm
talking droids and the force and it's
just so much stuff I would have to save
it for another video but I will point
out the way that they use the numbers in
2187 I think these are some of the last
words in the short film somebody walks
up and you say your numbers 2187 isn't
it so not that references would ever be
in competition with each other but isn't
it cool that sure in the original it was
Leia's cell on the Death Star but here
in this to 187 is exactly how people
refer to Finn and that's also the way
they use it in the short film they walk
up to him and call him number 21 87 very
cool reference moving on when phasma
reports back about fn-2187 going rogue
you can seed young finn maybe around 8
or 9 years old and probably the AG was
when he was taken by the first order
then as general Hux and kylo ren bicker
like siblings ren says that perhaps
Snoke should have used a clone army it's
obviously a reference to the past days
of the clone troopers based on Jango
Fett but it's also really interesting
because it's reinforcing stormtroopers
are real people but it actually is
opening up another really interesting
possibility they might not all be human
finn is the only one we've seen take his
helmet off
speaking of Finn he and Ray finally meet
and it's very fun and she doesn't need
hand-holding okay
follow me and the two of them and bb-8
run through this archway that marks the
entrance to niima outpost and it's
actually a design that we never got to
see but was supposed to mark the
entrance to Jabba the Hutt's palace way
back in Return of the Jedi it actually
makes a lot of sense here though since
niima outpost was named for NEMA the
Hutt a lady Hutt and thank God we didn't
have to see her also at this exact same
part the camera actually pans right past
the Millennium Falcon most people just
didn't notice it oh and of course Rey
calling it garbage is a callback to Luke
calling it a piece of junk which might
seem harsh since Rey collects junk for a
living but the Falcon actually is a
really old freighter ship now you can
actually see it at one point flying
around in the prequels and that's more
than 50 years before the events of this
movie but at least she's got it where it
counts its latest owner is revealed to
be unkar plutt you hear him yell that's
mine uh-huh one break grand theft auto's
it and this is a really good moment to
reveal another scene that was deleted
apparently uncle eat racks the Falcon to
takodana and maz kanata's castle he then
gets in a fight with our heroes and
finally something that's been teased at
before but we've never seen Chewie tears
his freakin arm ah it's not working
that's amazing I totally hope they shot
it and it makes its way onto a blu-ray
or something cuz I gotta see that wookie
yank that's not what I mean I'm back to
the chase scene we can see how the
Falcon has held up and it's not well at
all actually you can see the Gunners
seat that Finn's operating is really
rough and clunky and another parallel to
New Hope's actually shot very similarly
to Han and Luke's escape flight on the
Falcon they even celebrate the same way
the targeting computer is still the
exact same Nintendo Virtual Boy game but
we just save one clear upgrade that
somebody made there's a new antenna on
top of it because if you remember when
Lando told Han that he's gonna return
the Falcon without a scratch he almost
immediately gets the antenna smashed off
the top this new little antenna is
rectangular instead of round
I guess the advantage there is that
parents can't just recycle the old toy
they have to get the new one with the
rectangle or they're bad parents as Ray
pilots the Falcon she flies through the
hole of one of the old crashed starships
which is even bigger than the massive
inflictor we saw earlier and this is a
Super Star Destroyer it's actually
what's left of the ravager that also
went down in the battle of jakku it was
actually the last Super Star destroyed
the original empire hat and the Admiral
in charge of that ship her name was also
raised there's a lot of Ray's in this
neighborhood the story of that ship is
in the Star Wars book aftermath not lost
ours I'll link to that one in the
description too moving on after rey and
finn escaped the falcon gets pulled into
han and chewie snoo cargo ship the era
vana and it's gonna be a really long
time before anyone can definitely see it
clearly if it's there but apparently
there's a cargo container on this ship
it is numbered 9 9 0 6 7 5 3 that's the
same number we saw on a different cargo
crate in hangar 51 in Indiana Jones in
there it contains the Ark of the
Covenant
it's like Harrison Ford cannot get away
from that thing when Han and Chewie
board the million Falcon we get a ton of
quick nods to the original trilogy rey
and finn hiding out in the smuggling
compartment at Luke Han and obi-wan
hidden before are they're also wearing
the same atmospheric Mass that Han
Chewie and Leia we're in Empire Strikes
Back and that scene back then they're
out there cleaning off my Knock bats who
have that gross sucker mouth that is on
the glass of the Falcon and also the
raft our mouth and tentacles on the
Falcons cockpit glass and also Rey
references that Falcon famous show off
statistic about its Kessel run distance
but she gets it wrong it says it's 14
parsecs and a million nerds shout 12 at
the same time that Hondas and oh my god
that is a lot of references oh you want
more okay in that same sequence we get
cameos from the
really badass stars of the raid as
members of candy club and seriously they
are epic fighters you should watch the
raid to see that we also get Han saying
I have a bad feeling about this and it's
the third time Han has said that which
means he surpasses obi-wan as a person
that said that the most though he
already had that record if you count the
time that Indiana Jones said it in
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull Oh in the
Indiana Jones references go the other
direction when they're all trying to
outrun the wrath stars as one of them
comes rolling behind Han it's exactly
the same framing as the famous boulder
that's chasing Indy and Raiders of the
last Ark and when Finn is looking for
God he finds and tosses Luke raining
remote droid thing and it's actually
technically Hans remote but that doesn't
matter because the references are done
and oh my god when they are on the
Falcon it's like non-stop references but
luckily the movie takes us to circular
base there we get our first good look at
supreme leader snoke albeit he's just a
giant hologram Snoke is rumoured to
actually only be 7 feet tall only but
here it's probably just a reference to
the giant hologram of the Emperor's and
Empire Strikes Back but did you see that
huge crater and snoke's head there's
obviously a lot about his backstory that
we don't know moving on I'll get back to
the Falcon which means more references
been accidentally activating the hollow
chess game but what's actually really
cool about that moment is that it picks
up right after where the game left off
in a new hope the little guy that just
got body slammed he stands back up and
he smacks the opponent over the head
with a mallet and just good for the
little guy the other really cool thing
about the game is that they actually
went and shot new stop-motion animation
just like the way they did it in the
original then our crew arrives to Mazdas
pirate castle on takodana and inside
that castle there's a ton of other of
references and easter eggs in fact I bet
there's gonna be so many more revealed
over time but here's what I've got so
far the song you hear when you enter was
written and performed by Broadway's
lin-manuel miranda and JJ Abrams himself
there's also a funny little alien who's
played by Warwick Davis Warwick played
wicket the Ewok in Return of the Jedi
he also played two characters in Phantom
Menace it was a walled and weasel and
did W names continue because this aliens
name is wall oven it's a great name name
our kids that there's also a couple of
droids that are among the oldest ones
we've ever seen in Star Wars one of
which me8 d9 kind of looks like an
ancient ancestor to c-3po it's actually
rumored to be like thousands of years
old so these might be some of the first
droids ever but on to my favorite cameo
that we see in the castle and it's right
when we walk in the camera purposely
stays with this little creature guy for
some extra time and he looks a lot like
some sort of Wolfman that's a really
slick reference to the original New Hope
as in Star Wars as it was in 1977 the
non special edition you see back in 1997
there were the Star Wars special
editions and they did it again in 2004
and in 2011 George Lucas just kept going
back to the original trilogy and
updating the effects and painting a
bunch of scenes and adding a bunch of
CGI and that's why somehow Hayden
Christensen is in a movie that was
released in 1983 and how Han went from
shooting grito first to shooting in
self-defense so for the most part this
is the moment when people started really
hate on George Lucas and his unnecessary
CGI update one of the mascots of the
anti special edition movement was the
original moss eisely Cantina Wolfman and
how most people watching this video
right now I'd probably never even seen
this guy that's cuz Lucas Films has done
everything possible it can to erase him
and any reference to him from existence
they replaced him with two different
aliens in the original movie but JJ here
is very subtly sharing how he feels
about those special editions changes he
makes it super clear he thinks the
practical Wolfman belongs in a cantina
scene he reinforces that practical
effects preference when you realize
aside from Maz Kanata herself every
character in this entire scene is a
practical as a non CGI character and to
really point that out this scene
actually opens with an almost minute
long single take uncut shot showing us
all of them really cool oh and after
that uncut tracking shot we get our
quick Judah Friedlander cameo and he's
also not CGI
he's just Judah Friedlander in space now
all this stuff in maz kanata's is
clearly obviously just packed with
references but it makes you wonder what
stuff we didn't see because as it turns
out this is another sequence I had a
uncut out of it one of the deleted
scenes has ray gaining some extra wisdom
from this priest like figure his name
crossed her onlin but he was totally cut
out of the movie but even more drastic
Maz herself had this entire storyline
that was also completely cut out it's
cuz JJ realized that ultimately even if
she continued on with our heroes she
didn't actually need to be there with
them so going you cut the whole thing
out you can actually see a remnant of
Mazdas storyline in that one shop in the
trailers where she's handing Luke's
lightsaber to Leia instead of Finn oh
and as for deleted Leia scenes yeah
there were major deletions but we will
get back to that one of the most talked
about scenes is Rey's force vision and
that makes total sense cuz there's a lot
going on there if you actually hear
Vader's breathing not just at the
beginning of the vision but there are
hints of it before she's even got into
that room with the lightsaber and then
once the vision starts added to the
breathing is Luke screaming no and he
finds out that Vader's his dad
and that all goes with the location that
Rey is seen because that's the exact
place on Cloud City where Luke and Vader
had their epic fight then just before we
see all the Knights of Ren we see kylo
stabbed someone through the chest with
this saber but if you watch it closely
it almost seems like that person might
have been about to attack someone so
there's a slight chance that Ren's
actually saving someone with that attack
let me know what you think about that
when Yuri watch that scene up next in
the vision a large figure pulls young
ray away and that bulbous hand and that
deep voice saying quiet girl girl seems
to be very likely
unkar plutt so that could mean that he's
actually not such a bad guy or that
whoever left her with him just didn't
know what a jerk you'd be then right at
the end of the vision if you keep your
ears open here both a young and old
obi-wan with Alec Guinness voice saying
Rey and you and McGregor saying these
are the first steps that's so awesome
they had Ewan come in and record new
lines just for that but with the late
Alec Guinness they used this moment from
obi-wan saying afraid they'll be afraid
and they chopped it down so that Sir
Alec could save Rey very cool and one of
my favorite things they did it was just
so worth hearing his voice again now
also somewhere else in there you're
supposed to be able to hear Yoda's voice
same energy Josh but for the life of me
I've seen the movies like four times now
I have not been able to make it out let
me know in the comments if you hear it
and exactly where it is Owen about this
whole psychic vision thing that's
happening here with Rey that's all a
very specific but new to the movies Jedi
power called psychometry we're touching
an object allows a force user to see
visions of the objects memories and also
just to tap into the past and future and
it's a really big deal in Star Wars
actually and that's cuz almost no one
has ever had that power so it lends
credence to Rey being a very special
type of Jedi also really interesting to
note is that the few Jedi's that have
had that power were banned from using it
because being able to see through the
eyes of others and witness extreme
violence you guessed it Jedi's believe
that let's the dark Sider so potential
storyline for Brae in the future maybe I
don't know okay up next we have this
very crazy angry general Hux speech and
this section after the
opening storm trooper scene it's our
other major world war two reference this
whole thing is very closely modeled
after the speeches of Adolf Hitler
not just the screaming and the uniforms
but the body language the colors the
troop formations and really blatantly
the stormtroopers arms shooting up high
lean hooks Nazis have actually always
been the main inspiration for the Empire
and Hitler's rise to power is very
similar to the way the Emperor did it
force awakens actually picks up where
that left off because after World War 2
many Nazis went into hiding in Argentina
and that's almost exactly what happens
after the Empire shatter their remnants
also go into hiding in Argentina now
getting a high in the unknown region of
the galaxy where they could all go be
evil and the New Republic would have
noticed also the way the first order
takes young children and then they
basically brainwash them into believing
all their to fit nonsense and then they
turn them into stormtroopers at all is
pretty much exactly what the Nazis did
with the Hitler Youth but enough Nazis
okay let's talk about what happens after
the speech they use Starkiller base to
destroy the hosnian system including
hosnian prime which is the capital of
the new republic and since we've seen
how it works that's the first time that
a star has been utilized in an act of
war in a Star Wars movie and it's called
the hosnian system as a reference to the
famed Los Angeles high school teacher
Jim Hosny who taught film to like
everybody in Hollywood when they were
teens including all of JJ Abrams is
regular producing partners Bryan Burk
who produced this movie Berta Archie and
Alex Kurtzman who co-produced the Star
Trek movies with JJ's posny even taught
the son of Lawrence Kasdan who co-wrote
this movie and returned to the Jedi and
Empire Strikes Back so I guess all these
people just felt like they owed this old
high school teacher something so they
named an entire star system after him
and then they blew it up but anyway back
to the destroyed New Republic Capitol we
actually only get this really brief shot
of it before it's blown up
except that one shot is a remnant of
another huge storyline that was totally
cut out of the movie and it's the big
Leia storyline that I alluded to earlier
so in that one shot of hosnian prime the
camera focuses on this girl that you
might have wondered is she important out
did we see her before well she used to
be
important that's course Ella and I'm
gonna save a lot of these smaller
details for another video but basically
in the time that's passed since Return
of the Jedi the New Republic really
desperately wanted to pretend that
everything was fine they wanted to
ignore everything the first order was
doing even though it was breaking all
these treaties that they had established
Princess Leia originally was seen as
this kind of hero when she kept pointing
out how stupid it was to ignore the
first order everyone in the Senate kind
of started to hate her and they
definitely stopped trusting her so
that's why Leia formed the resistance
separate from the New Republic and there
was a whole storyline in the movie that
explained all that in it now general
Leia feels that she finally has enough
proof to the New Republic to act and
send their fleet to take out the first
order or arrest them or do something
because they know that they're building
this insane weapon but since she knows
that no one in the New Republic trusts
her anymore she has to send one of her
commander's horse Ella to meet with the
New Republic Senate to convince them to
prepare for war or do you like anything
at all yeah all of this stuff was
comfort time and there were also scenes
in it where we learned that c-3po is in
charge of these droids that spy on the
first order Leia gives a passionate
speech to her troops there's all kinds
of characters and leaders of Naboo whole
new chancellor and it's all gone we do
however know how the story line ends cuz
we see the killer son being hit hosnian
prime and there's course Ella's
screaming and she's standing next to the
new chancellor and yeah poof they're
they're dead if you thought the movie
was missing a bit of the three politics
of the New Republic or Leia being a
really badass general keep your fingers
crossed for the deleted scenes because I
think that's all in there okay so then
later when the first order attacks Maz
is Castle Han uses Chuy's bow caster and
even though he actually used it a little
earlier in the movie you find out that
these two times look the only times Han
has ever used Chewie signature weapon
and when he sees that it can blow a
freakin stormtrooper across the
battlefield of course yeah he's a big
fan of it later when the stormtroopers
surround Chewie and Han and have them
put their hands up it's all a callback
to the moment in Return of the Jedi
where the same thing happens except here
the resistance comes to the rescue and
back then it was a bunch of teddy bears
or yox oh and in this epic rescue sneak
attack we get a moment where finn
watches poe flying and says that that's
a little pilot and yeah he is because in
that 20-second uncut shot ho takes out
hentai fighters and three stormtroopers
if you've ever heard of the concept of
an ace pilot that's defined as a pilot
who has shot down at least five enemy
planes over the course of their career
so that means Poe is a double base pilot
in just these 20 seconds he's definitely
one of the best pilots ever and
considering the gift that Luke gave his
family in the comic book shattered
Empire there's a chance that there's
actually some force at work in Poe
linked to that story in the description
- and then when we finally do get Leia
in this movie she arrives in a modified
version of a B wing from Return of the
Jedi it's actually another ship it's not
like a new version it's been cobbled
together from parts left over from the
original trilogy and it really
underlines that the resistance doesn't
have nice anything like all of their
stuff is left over from the Galactic
Civil War even their leaders then right
after she lands we get is really easy to
miss cameo right before han and Leia
even talk we see what seems like a
standard protocol droid but if you look
closely it's actually c-3po of course
you probably didn't recognize them
because of the red arm okay no I'm
kidding yes I know you've recognized
them but did you know that the red arm
is going to get its own story in another
part of the saga apparently has to do
with a sacrifice that another droid made
and talking about it makes c-3po very
sad and it's kind of feels like Threepio
got like really close to another droid
while r2 was asleep I mean sure good for
him it is legal now anyway once the gang
goes over to the secret resistance base
back on the car we get a few more cameos
including Carrie Fisher's daughter
Billie lourd Ken Leung from loss and
JJ's own good luck charm Greg Grunberg
who's in pretty much everything JJ does
he even snuck him in a Kirk stepdad in
Star Trek that cars it
but here he's snap Wexley a grownup
version of teman Wexley from that Star
Wars aftermath book the most interesting
thing there is that in the book it
doesn't come out and say it but it
leaves you with the feeling that he
could have some of the force in him so
let's just keep an eye on snap as the
movies keep coming out oh and that
Doctor Who is like hardcore flirting
with Chewie
he's like calling him all brave and
stuff she's Lady Shackleton from Downton
Abbey but more interesting she's the
niece of Christopher Lee who played
Count Dooku now she's Chuy's girlfriend
which is just asking for trouble with
moss also the resistance base here looks
almost identical to the rebel bases in
the past and it's like oh god the
resistance just needs some new funding
then when Han and Leia are talking about
their son who has been seduced by the
dark side she says there is still light
in him I know which is almost an exact
quote of her mama Padme saying about
Anakin you can count on both those
references to Lube thing about Vader
there is still coding and it's
interesting that Luke and Padme are
saying it to obi-wan and here Leia is
saying it to Han it's kind of like that
will be one of this movie then after
kylo has kidnapped Rey and force
infiltrates her mind it's worth pointing
out that he sees her dreams of a place
that has a vast ocean and an island
which exactly describes where Ray finds
Luke at the end of the movie also
interesting despite kylo being the
ultimate fanboy it's actually Rey who
brings up Darth Vader and she's the only
person to mention that name in this
movie his presence is definitely
everywhere though and his presence and
this is a round where Ray famously pulls
a Jedi mind trick on a stormtrooper and
it's actually only the fifth time we've
seen that work in the seven movies so
far and the stormtrooper just so happens
to be played by Daniel Craig I'll say
his voice sounds super American actually
so it's a pretty easy miss but his
character's name is a little less subtle
it's JB double-oh-seven back on the car
the resistance starts their plan to
attack Starkiller base and we get lots
of glimpses that all the characters
whose teens were cut out sorry to them
but we also get reintroduced to little
nyan
who Lascaux piloted the Falcon with
Lando we also get everybody's favorite
Mallis Admiral Ackbar and while it was
really awesome to see him it cannot
believe that they didn't have Akbar come
running out when r2 and bb-8 put their
star charts together and have him
yelling it's a map missed opportunity if
you ask me the fact Oberon Starkiller
base after Rey has escaped we get a nice
little tour of the facilities and it's
just interesting to know how you can see
lots of places where the mechanical
structures give way to natural rock
formations in the halls and it really
helps illustrate that story killer base
is not just some man-made weapon it's
actually carved out of the rock of this
already existing icy world we just never
learned the planets original name after
the Falcon gets through the shield's and
lands on star killer base there was
another deleted scene that has snow
troopers searching the Falcon but you do
get to see those snow troopers for
literally less than three seconds on the
base and their costumes are exactly the
same designs that were meant to be used
way back on top and Empire but they
didn't end up getting used until now
then we find out that Finn is a janitor
and that's not just a good setup for why
Finn knows about the trash compactor it
actually answers a big question posed in
the famous nerd analysis movie clerks
think the average stormtrooper knows how
to install a toilet main clothes they
know is killing in white uniforms and
now we know yeah actually stormtroopers
have low level non war related
specialties like sanitation side note
the director of clerks is Kevin Smith
and he's a huge Star Wars nerd and he's
got a voice credit in the force awakens
somewhere I just have not been able to
find it let me know if you know where it
is help above in the aerial attack on
star killer base we get some great shots
of resistance pilot ello at sea and
that's a reference to hello nasty The
Beastie Boys album fat JJ's a big fan oh
it has intergalactic on it which is a
really good fit better than the sabotage
song he used in Star Trek
this helmet also says in our bash born
to Ill which is a combination of the
born to kill helmet from Full Metal
Jacket and licensed until the first
Beastie Boys studio album and Damned JJ
deluxe who loves the Beastie Boys and
another resistance pilot jazz pava is
actually introduced in the book the
weapon of a Jedi where she's like super
into Luke link below but the actress
Jessica Han wick she marks our third
game of Thrones cameo you might remember
her as one of the sand snakes from Dorne
who's like really into whips also when
Yuri watch this sequence after Chewie
has told Han that he's cold pay extra
attention to Han and Finn's jacket it's
very subtle but Chewie makes sure that
even though he's cold his old friend Han
gets his jacket bag and at some point it
seems like Finn has learned from this
because he's given his new friend Ray
his jacket and this ever-changing jacket
thing it's just a nice way to show the
growing relationship between Finn and
Rey as it compares to Han and Chewie but
it's actually probably something that we
see a lot more of in another deleted
scene and this one Han and Chewie have
gone to set the charges for the bombs
but Rey and Finn have to go to a
different part of the base to give Han
and Chewie access in order to get there
quickly rey and finn steal another
vehicle they take out some snow troopers
and rey shows off more of a piloting of
their snow speeder and you can actually
still see the snow speeder in the
background just before they run back
into the base another interesting choice
and JJ's imagery is less subtle than the
opening shots but it's still pretty cool
when Hans talking to kylo and the light
on Kyla's face changes from light to
darkness and then his entire face gets
cast in red light like the fifth color
just as his descent into the darkside is
complete it might not be the most subtle
imagery but it's just straight-up a cool
way to tell us information without
having to explain it just literally with
dialogue also in this moment we're
spoiler spoiler spoiler spoiler how are
you still watching this if you care
about spoilers a moment where Han dies
you'll note that Rey and Finn have to
watch their mentor ty be struck down by
a lightsaber and it's all just mirrors
pretty exactly Luke watching Vader kill
obi-wan and also again it makes Han this
movies obi-wan then Hong's body falls
down into the void and it's reminiscent
of a bunch of other Star Wars falling
deaths including Darth Maul mace windu
overfed the M
kind of similar to Luke falling and
Empire Strikes Back mostly similar to
the Emperor and Darth Maul accepted you
know Darth Maul didn't actually die then
very crazy so for another time point is
was it following they got a started
having safety nets or something okay
moving on then bin and eventually Rey
have some pretty badass duels with kylo
out in the snow and man by the way
lightsabers at night melting the snow
that was all very cool but also cool is
the fighting style that they're using
it's actually lifted from the original
trilogy despite modern technology being
able to recreate all the flips and
parkour and fancy stuff they did in the
prequels it actually makes sense that in
both the original trilogy and now in
force awakens no Jedi's have actually
gotten the level of training that allows
for all those fancy moves even Luke
never gets that great at handstands
though in their universe it does make a
lot of sense that this is a battle of
mostly brute force and a jabbing style
of attack the prequel fighting style has
been taught a long time also another
reference despite being heard Kyle is
actually trying a very cocky one-handed
style of fighting he's mimicking Darth
Vader's form when he was twined with
Luke that cockiness just doesn't work
out quite as well for kylo and moments
later when the lightsaber is stuck in
the snow and Rey force Yanks it out it's
a lot like how Luke did it in the
beginning of empire there's a much more
interesting reference going on here to a
very old but very legendary tale that
actually inspires a lot of this entire
movie but since we're almost done I'm
just gonna point out very quickly some
of the last Easter eggs and references
before I go into that they included
trench run much like the one in a new
hope but just for a moment we're posed
flying in the trench of Starkiller base
and after the win in the celebration
back on Dakar but just before you see
leia flying solo at the bottom of the
screen you'll see just like a little
glimpse of our to katy a pink version of
r2d2 that was created by Star Wars fan
Alvin Johnson as a tribute to his
daughter Katie who will unfortunately
died back in 2005 but by putting the
Droid in this movie she now has a legacy
as big as Star Wars and then the star
map that bb-8 and r2d2 put together
actually very specific style of map it
existed in Knights of the Old Republic
these maps are very special they're very
old they chart many systems that there's
no other record of and these maps might
even have connections to the force
itself so they're really fancy maps
finally the last basic language words of
the film are may the force be with you
but the actual final lines of the film
just like the first ones are series of
beeps and whistles except instead of
bb-8 there from r2d2 but ok returning to
the huge reference that is going on
throughout the entire movie let's go
back to that battle in the snow that Ray
had had a vision of before this entire
story of hers and kylo ren's is very
reminiscent to the tales of King Arthur
the force awakens actually gives us all
sorts of little references to that time
period
remember when kylo Ren's lightsaber was
first unveiled there was all that
attention paid to the cross guard that's
because that's something we've never
seen in a lightsaber before but it's
very common in medieval broadswords also
kylos appearance is similar to that of
King Arthur's nemesis Mordred the shaggy
hair the dark clothes it's actually a
look that's seen a lot in medieval
warden type characters kind of like Jon
Snow is or the Sheriff of Nottingham
also some other uniquely medieval
references include a castle that's
covered in old banners stormtroopers
using shields kylos men being referred
to as knights and knights of ren even
feel like the knights of the round table
that surround king arthur except today
thank kylos arthur and wrong oh and one
of his other soldier types wears the
metallic armor of a knight but back to
being mistaken about him Mordred isn't
the chosen one and neither is Kyle oh
just like in King Arthur's origin the
chosen one is actually the young poor
orphan type so Kyle thinks the
lightsaber or sword is his birthright
especially because there's an evil
practitioner of dark magic Snowboard
Morgan la Fey and Arthur stories
misleading him but when the sword slash
saber is placed in stone or in this case
snow the one who thinks it's his
birthright can't get it out and instead
the sword will only go to the true
chosen one a young Arthur or in our case
Rey now pulling the sword out of the
stone men are
was destined to become king so we'll see
what that means for Rey but it's also
worth noting that a lot of those
Arthurian stories a lot of versions of
it Mordred and Arthur are related so
that could be a clue to Ray and Ren's
relationship it's also worth noting that
a lot of people have used this same
comparison to describe the original
trilogy with Luke and Vader and those
roles and the Emperor as the Morgan
LeFay type and actually I'll say that
even if that's the case it also works
because if you say Luke is actually King
Arthur well in those stories when Arthur
is gravely hurt his mythical sword
Excalibur is sent flying into the hands
of the old and wise lady of the lake she
holds the sword for safekeeping until
it's either needed again or until
Arthur's time to return wolf Maz is our
Lady of the lake she not only sees that
the sword is needed again giving it to
Rey but it also makes its way back to
the original King Arthur to mark his
return when Rey hands it to Luke oh also
remember where Mazdas castle is yeah she
lives on a lake okay that was fun and
holy crest so many freakin observations
and references though actually what the
hell one more quick observation for
right at the end when we see Luke before
Rey has interrupted him and before he
looks away it looks like he's looking at
a gravestone a lot of theories right you
tell me what you think that could be
about in the comments and let me know
anything else you think I might have
missed I did leave out some things that
I didn't find too interesting but some
other stuff is in those other trailers
breakdown videos that I mentioned so
check those out or any other videos that
you can might interest you there's a lot
of them but if you like this video make
sure to share it I think there's some
really good stuff here so it's a good
share I've been phill'd Molina you can
follow me on twitter at fimo and follow
this channel for video updates at new
rockstars subscribe if you want to see
more stuff like this in your feed
regularly cuz this is what I live for
and this is what we make after me I'm
just gonna go see Star Wars again I know
there's stuff that I'm still missing and
I I'm just so mad I haven't heard the
Yoda line clearly I gotta go
bye